it's not enough to just survive
something right that's not the point of
life you've got a thrive and now Prince
Harry's aunt is speaking out in the wake
of his and wife Megan Merkel's royal
exits apart from the Queen's official
statements the Royals have remained
pretty tight-lipped about Megan and
Harry's departure but in a new interview
with The Sunday Times Sophie the
Countess of Wessex recalls trying to
help Megan navigate her public struggle
with the royal family she tells the
outlet quote we all try to help any new
member of the family I think I really
tried to adopt this British sensibility
of a stiff upper lip but I think that
what that does internally is probably
really damaging Sophie who's married to
Prince Charles's brother Prince Edward
grew up in a middle-class family and
worked for a PR firm before becoming a
countess like Megan who is currently in
the middle of a court case with
associated newspapers after the Mail on
Sunday published her handwritten letter
to estranged father Thomas Markel Sophie
also struggled with the critical British
press and even had topless photos
published shortly before her 1999
wedding though the countess does admit
she had more time to adjust to royal
life than Megan did Sophie tells The
Times quote remember I'd had five years
to adjust and for our six-month
engagement I was even staying in
Buckingham Palace not that you
necessarily know how it will pan out
Megan dated Harry for less than two
years before their May 28
if I do something wrong the first woman
to go oh my gosh I'm so sorry but never
do that but when people are saying
things that are just untrue and they're
being told they're untrue but they're
allowed to still say them I don't know
anybody in the world that would feel
like that's okay and that's that's
different than just screwed
Sophie and Megan have been photographed
chatting on numerous occasions here they
are back in March at the Sussex is final
royal engagement on Commonwealth Day
weeks before Megan and Harry stepped
down from their royal duties on March
31st Sophie tells the outlet quote I
just hope they will be happy I hope that
helps you understand what did it come to
that I would step my family back from
all I have ever known
just take us to take a step forward into
what I hope can be a more peaceful life
the Duke and Duchess of Sussex have
since relocated to Megan's hometown of
Los Angeles with their one-year-old son
Archie let's go to the next page look
arch please settled into their lives in
LA and this is the pattern to the future
I'm told that they feel a great sense of
freedom and they're really enjoying
their new lives and they're enjoying
being able to do things a bit more on
their terms
[Music]